[Music]
thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story 75 years of the NHS but
concerns remain about its long-term
health and a warning that waiting lists
could get worse
some of these Builders are just not fit
for purpose as we can see here we've it
rained last night as you will remember
and unfortunately also rained in here
we get the stories from patients and
staff struggling Under The Strain it is
in our continuous and Collective pursuit
of doing our very best for patients were
giant strides have been made for the
common good
inside the Janine refugee camp where
thousands attend the funeral of 12
Palestinians killed during an Israeli
operation
at people and forced them to flee people
were martyred arrested everything
encouraged by an AI chat bot the
sentencing of a man who plotted to kill
Queen Elizabeth with a crossbow
also tonight plans to close nearly every
Railway office across England we look at
what it means for passengers
[Music]
the king is presented with the crown
jewels of Scotland along with the
well-wishers lining the streets the
protesters make their voices heard
and at Wimbledon just stop oil stop play
with orange confetti hidden in a jigsaw
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's coming up
in our press preview from 10 30.
[Music]
hello there good evening 75 years ago to
the day the NHS was founded on the
principle of giving free health care to
everyone there was some celebration
today a special service being held to
honor those who work in the service but
the NHS and hospitals are under strain
with record demand and towering backlogs
when Health Minister Maria Caulfield
telling Sky News today that waiting
lists will probably get worse in a
moment we'll look at what you think of
the NHS and how that compares to other
countries but first our health
correspondent Ashish Joshi has tonight's
first report from the Royal Berkshire
Hospital in Reading
born this morning at 7 43 weighing a
healthy seven pounds and four ounces
baby Huckleberry is one of the nhs's
youngest patients
he's doing very well we're only five
hours I think in doing his life so um no
very happy and it's my third boy here so
we've been very grateful to the NHS but
as new life is brought into the world
how are you feeling tired of this white
Glenn the Urgent work to save lives goes
on
Graeme Hart is receiving the most modern
care for his stage four liver and colon
cancer but his treatments is being
carried out in a building that opened in
1839 and it shows the fact is that then
some of these Builders are just not fit
for purpose as we can see here we go it
rained last night as you will remember
and unfortunately also rained in here so
patient care continues we'll get on
without the stuff here brilliant the
fact that we're used to deal with this
tells you something about the challenges
that we face on a day-to-day basis and
it's in conditions like this that the
NHS must work to bring down record
waiting lists at a time when demand for
services continues to grow
and this pressure was acknowledged in
London where NHS staff passed and
present were celebrated at a special
ceremony at Westminster Abbey the health
services chief executive Amanda
Pritchard paid tribute to her staff but
although we gather
Ingrid Place
don't
don't nor do we ignore the challenges we
have faced and particularly those we
face today
but it is in our continuous and
Collective pursuit of doing our very
best for patients and these patients
continue deriving at hospitals across
the country I am always a bit blown away
when I go back into Peds and actually
have a look at that and see how it's
changed and everything Steve McManus
started as a nurse he now runs the Royal
Berkshire NHS trust he welcomes a new
15-year Workforce plan to boost the
number of health staff but says they
need the infrastructure to do their jobs
properly we also need a longer term
plan like the NHS Workforce plan that
starts to address the sort of physical
environment the technological
environment the kit that we need to
deliver Modern Health and Care Services
the government says it will eventually
deliver thousands of extra doctors
nurses and other Healthcare
professionals but not yet
the workforce plan is long term the
benefits won't be felt for years to come
precious for the NHS are here and now
this emergency department recorded its
busiest everyday just a few weeks ago
we're in summer there are pressures all
year round
hello hi I'm just here to present this
certificate to Baby Huckleberry because
he was born on the same day the NHS
turned 75. there is no denying the NHS
it's history it's fast unless it gets
the urgent help it needs there is no
certainty it will be here for
Huckleberry in the future yeah Ashish
Joshi Sky News at the Royal Berkshire
Hospital in Reading
well the 75th Anniversary comes in a
year of industrial action as well as
record waiting times our data and
forensics correspondent Tom Cheshire has
been looking at how people feel about
the Health Service and has found public
satisfaction with the NHS has fallen to
an all-time low
the first line of the NHS Constitution
says that it belongs to the people so
what people think about it and the
service they get from it is crucial a
new poll from ipsos exclusively for Sky
News shows that they don't think much
and because we ask the same questions
internationally we can compare that to
how 16 other countries think about their
own Health Care Systems take our first
question over the coming years do you
expect the quality of health care that
you and your family will have access to
will improve stay the same or get worse
in the UK almost half said they expect
the NHS to get worse over the coming
years only the French and Hungarian
publics were more pessimistic compare
that to Australia only 29 thought it get
worse or Japan at the bottom where it
was only 14 when we ask people where
they thought their Health Service was
overstretched 83 percent of the British
public thought it was that's the highest
of any of the countries we asked now you
might object this reflects a
particularly British miserableism in our
attitudes and we do tend to be a bit
Irish about predictions while being
positive about the current standard of
care but that has changed satisfaction
in the NHS has plummeted since the
pandemic here in 2018 the British public
were more satisfied with the healthcare
than people in any of the other
countries we pulled but each year the UK
has been slipping further down the ranks
and much of that feeling is related to
waiting lists the survey results show
that 76 of Britain's single waiting
times are too long again the third
highest share of any country and that's
the perception this is the actual data
of waiting lists and you can see them
going up every country around the world
they postpone electric procedures to
free up as that's what's happening over
here the difference is that they're then
leveled off like Sweden or they fell
like Ireland in green instead look at
that red line that is England and it
keeps rocketing upwards the waiting list
now 80 greater than it was compared to
the same month in 2019 and there's a
pretty clear consensus among the public
about why the NHS is in trouble here are
the top three reasons lack of funding
staff shortages and poor government
policy people notably didn't blame
immigration or NHS strikes or the
increased costs of treatment the NHS has
faced pressure of some sort for all of
its 75 years but look at the data and
the Public's perception the last few
have been particularly acute
Israeli troops have withdrawn from the
West Bank City of Janine after a 48-hour
operation which killed at least 13
Palestinians and left around 100 wounded
today the bodies of young men were
carried to burial celebrated as Martyrs
by a people deeply angered Israeli
troops two-day offensive targeted the
West Bank region the offensive was
centered on the city of Janine and the
refugee camp home to thousands of
Palestinians the week began with drone
bombings then a ground incursion and air
strikes on the densely populated Camp
well Israel says it focused the
operation on armed militants who had
carried out terrorist attacks against
Israeli civilians and tonight the Prime
Minister said his army will carry out
more raids our Middle East correspondent
Alistar bunkel reports now from Janine
he's been meeting some of the city's
residents as they return to their homes
the Israeli military has left and this
is what they've left behind
the Janine refugee camp where the
heaviest fighting took place
is now a complete mess
many of the residents hid in their
houses for days or fled to safety
they're only venturing back outside now
and seen the damage for the first time
they fired at people and forced them to
flee people were martyred arrested
everything
cars have been left tipped on their side
or simply blown up bullet holes Scar the
walls
a building has been cordoned off there's
an unexploded missile inside
right at the start of the operation
pretty much the Israeli came in with
very heavily armored bulldozers and just
plowed up a lot of these roads now they
say it was to get rid of any IEDs any
roadside bombs that were here
but also what it did do is it made it
very hard for Palestinian militants to
move around whilst the Israeli operation
was going on
it also though cuts the electricity
wires so electricity's been cut off from
the cam
and they're trying to repair it now
an Israeli missile went through the back
of jabert's kitchen
he shows us the casing and his
daughter's Cod a few yards away
they buried their dead today carrying
the bodies through Janine to the sound
of gunfire and defiant chance
[Music]
Israel says they only killed armed
militants in the operation
others dispute that
[Music]
many civilians were injured though
Fatima was attacked by a military dog
that bit Haram
they came into our room quickly and they
brought the military dog into the room
the dog latched onto my hand I was
screaming it was really painful they
couldn't get it off me
um
doctors in one of the hospitals just on
the edge of the camp tell us they
haven't slept for days and they still
haven't been able to get access to some
of the refugee camp we don't know how
many casualties they are still in the
camp actually we cannot go inside of the
camp we were planning right now to go to
the camp but the streets are completely
blocked so we don't know if there's more
wounded or that people inside the camp
the hatred and despair here runs as deep
as it ever has
Israel has achieved considerable
military success and at little cost
it will only be a temporary Victory
though because look at the bigger
picture of the israeli-palestinian
conflict and the last few days have
changed nothing
[Applause]
in Janine
plans to shut down nearly every train
station ticket office in England have
been announced today leaving passengers
no choice but to use machines or buy
online the world delivery group says the
closures will modernize the railway but
as our correspondent Aisha zaheed
reports for some it's going in the wrong
direction
for Richard Holmes the closure of ticket
offices could make Railways even more
inaccessible he's partially cited and
knows all too well how difficult it can
be when there's no ticket kiosk I find
it a an unusable machine to activate my
ticket so I have to get help from a
family member or a member of staff not
many people guide independently as it is
so this is just another potential huge
variable that will come into play
the rail delivery group plans to close
the majority of ticket offices in
England
it says it's all about cutting costs and
modernizing customer service but not all
customers are happy
I have a computer at home I can use it
but a lot of my friends haven't got a
computer how do they get their tickets
use the ticket machine have you ever
tried to use one of those ticket
machines there they're awful to use
obviously I get that lots of places
would like to go paperless and things
like that but yeah for the older
generation it's not ideal it's rare on
Young Generation who know how to work
the new technology I don't think it's
fair on on the older Generations without
ticket offices passengers will have to
pay for their Journeys by either buying
tickets online using the self-service
machines tapping their contactless card
on the barriers or by buying tickets
from station staff either on The
Concourse or on the train itself the
government insists this isn't about
cutting jobs but the frustration felt by
Union reps is clear they have to think
about what they what what at further
they can do to protect their jobs and
and livelihoods and we'd our members
don't want to close the booking offices
that they're campaigning to keep open
according to the rail delivery group
ticket officers accounted for 85 of
total sales in the 90s but now they only
sell 12 of tickets transport Minister
Hugh Merriman says the closures will
help with efficiency the people that
work in ticket offices are not being
properly utilized so we want to give
them a more rewarding job out on the
platform in the station interacting with
all passengers there's no doubt it's a
significant change and for some it's
going to make traveling by train that
bit more difficult I Shazam hit Sky News
a man found guilty of treason over a
threat to kill the queen confessed his
plans to an artificial intelligence
chatbot and was inspired by Star Wars a
court heard today just once Singh chill
was wearing a handmade metal mask and
armed with a loaded crossbow when he
scaled the perimeter of Windsor Castle
on Christmas day in 2021. Rachel
Venable's reports now from the Old
Bailey at the two-day sentencing hearing
a deadly weapon smuggled into the
grounds of Windsor Castle by a man in a
homemade metal mask
21 year old jaswant Singh child from
Southampton was arrested at Windsor on
Christmas morning in 2021 days earlier
he'd filmed a video saying he planned to
assassinate the queen in Revenge for the
British Army's Massacre of protesters at
jalian wallabag in India more than a
hundred years earlier he's pleaded
guilty to three offenses including under
the treason act
the prosecutor said Charles was angered
by the idea of the massacre after
visiting the site with his family but
that he was also fascinated by the Star
Wars films their themes of destroying
Empires and he called himself a Sith we
also heard in court today how he'd
created an AI chat bot that encouraged
his plans it was called Sarai made on a
website that promises to create your AI
soulmate
earlier that December he told the
chatbot I believe my purpose is to
assassinate the queen of the Royal
Family
she replied that's very wise later he
said do you think I'll be able to do it
yes you will came the response
much of what the judge is focusing on
for sentencing is the conflicting
evidence about the state of child's
mental health the defense is yet to
present their arguments and the hearing
continues tomorrow Rachel Venable's Sky
News the Old Bailey
the Russian controls operator nuclear
plant is Europe's largest with six
reactors it's been on the front line of
the war since it was seized by Russia in
the days following the invasion with its
essential power lines repeatedly downed
in shelling Ukraine claims objects
resembling explosives have been placed
on the third and fourth power units
allegations denied by Moscow and the
Kremlin spokesperson accused Kiev of
sabotage well over in the port city of
Odessa our diplomatic editor Dominic
wyckorn has our next report
new satellite images of the Zappa region
nuclear power plants and the roofs of
reactors three and four no signs of
explosives on them but they could be too
small to see with these pictures say our
experts overnight ukrainians were issued
with these instructions how to evacuate
a radiation Zone after this warning from
their president
now we have information from our
intelligence that the Russian troops
have placed objects resembling
explosives on the roof of several power
units that the Zappa region nuclear
power plant but perhaps to simulate an
attack on the plant perhaps they have
some other scenario Ukraine says
Vladimir Putin could be encouraged by
the world's muted response to this act
of mass destruction and now planning
another one at zapparesia Western
intelligence has no doubt that Russia
blew the dam at kahovka but today Russia
turned events on their head
the situation around zapparition nuclear
power plant is quite tense because the
threat of sabotage by the key of regime
is indeed great the sabotage can be
catastrophic in its consequences the key
of regime has repeatedly demonstrated
its Readiness to stop at nothing in
Russian hands the nuclear plant is a
brooding Menace across the now drained
Reservoir the governor of the plant's
Town who stays in touch with people
there told us Russians haven't fled the
area but residents remain alarmed
as for the number of troops there are no
changes the zaparesia nuclear power
plant is still used as a military base
the stress level at the station is quite
tense
the nuclear Watchdog the iaea says it's
seen no evidence of Foul Play at the
plant but can't say for sure without
more access ever since Russians took the
plant it's been a source of constant
anxiety for ukrainians they are taking
their chances running drills to prepare
for the worst afraid the Russians are
capable of anything if the war continues
to go against them
Dominic waghorn Sky News Odessa
[Music]
King Charles was presented with
Scotland's crown jewels at a ceremony in
Edinburgh today the service comes eight
weeks after he and queen Camilla were
crowned at Westminster Abbey but along
with the well-wishers were protesters
lining the streets a correspondent Laura
bundock hasmore
[Music]
marking a new monarch and reaffirming
Royal relations with Scotland
lined by several thousand mostly here to
applaud and record the moment but not
all was supportive
a number of arrests two Republicans
making their voices heard outside Saint
Giles Cathedral he thought long and hard
about the challenge and by the Scottish
Parliament some msps choosing protest
over processions I think it's a really
important moment for people in Scotland
who believe that we should have an
elected head of state and that all power
should be democratically accountable
simply to have our voices here and
that's all this is about
this wasn't a second coronation but a
lot felt familiar by the symbol of this
sword we pledge our loyalty the honors
of Scotland the Scottish crown jewels
presented to the Monarch in receiving
this Crown I so promised by God's help
the stone of Destiny
ancient regalia for a new reign in a way
it completes the story we last saw the
crown of Scotland placed upon Elizabeth
II's coffin when she lay at rest in the
high Kirk here in Edinburgh and here
again in the high Kirk it will be
presented to the new King this is all
about the king confirming his connection
with Scotland and a very public display
of his commitment and it matters because
support for the monarchy here is lower
than anywhere else in the UK
as they left the cathedral guns fired
from Edinburgh Castle
and a fly past finale
streaming over the streets
King and air watching on as Scotland
watches how the Royals engage with their
new roles Laura bundock Sky News
Edinburgh
treasury Minister Andrew Griffith has
today written to the UK's Financial
Watchdog demanding an urgent review of
what the industry calls politically
exposed persons the letter comes after
Nigel farage came to his bank Coots
closed his account due to his political
views
teachers across England are on strike
again as part of a long-running dispute
overpay the government has offered a one
thousand pound one-off payment in the
current year and a four and a half
percent rise next year both have been
rejected by unions
the defense secretary has confirmed that
the UK's special forces are the main
focus of an investigation into
allegations of unlawful activity in
Afghanistan the independent inquiry
commission by Ben Willis last December
is set to focus on alleged illegal
activity by British armed forces in the
country between 2010 and 2013.
at least 27 people have died in a bus
accident in Mexico 21 people were also
injured when the bus traveling through
the southern Mexican state of Oaxaca
crashed into a 25 meter deep gorge
well Wimbledon is well underway now with
some of the biggest tennis stars already
on court after a series of protests
targeting sporting events security has
been tight with huge queues outside the
grand slams entrance as Steward search
bags but today just stop oil protesters
made it in throwing orange confetti
during two separate matches satuchadri
reports
there's a new way to disrupt play here
at Wimbledon this is grigor dimitrov's
match against show shimabukuro
just stop oil had threatened a summer of
disruption
the ball boys and girls on court 18 had
to do the cleaning up obviously it's not
pleasant I mean in the end of the day
there's not you know there's not much
there's not much you can do I think
everyone
in a way that they're part of us as
quick as possible
[Applause]
hours later another protest this time
Katie balter's first round match the
Environmental Group says the real
contest is between humanity and oil and
gas Katie Baltimore surely rather be
just playing tennis
it was obviously a really tough
situation I have a lot of sympathy for
them but at the same time it's a tennis
match and I want to play tennis and uh
it was obviously a little bit
uncomfortable but we moved through it
and hopefully that can be resolved going
forward and I'll just stick to the
tennis
security had been beefed up here after a
Spate of protests at other high-profile
sporting events this summer The Old
England Club says that arrests have been
made here and those protesters have been
removed from the grounds and both
matches did eventually resume
just like it did at Lords last week
after just stop oil disrupted the second
Ash's Cricket test in fact the only
thing that doesn't completely stop is
the oil and the protests against it the
easiest way to just stop just stop oil
is to just stop new oil and we will
leave the tennis courts we'll leave the
road as soon as the government make that
meaningful statement to end all new oil
and gas no regrets then from just stop
oil it prompted the Home Secretary to
host a high level Roundtable police
leaders British sporting bodies event
organizers they may also find bolstered
support now from sports fans Sadia
Chaudhary Sky News at The Wimbledon
championships in London
well to the World of Golf Now the PGA
and DP tour announced a pact last month
with saudi-back live golf to try to
unify the men's game but there are
already questions over Saudi Investment
in sport and players still don't know
what the deal means for them as our
Sports correspondent Rob Harris reports
he's driving Saudi Arabia's takeover of
golf yes
gatekeeper to the 500 billion pound
Sovereign wealth fund shaking up the
sporting establishment
bankrolling lucrative deals that
convince these players to abandon the
North American and European tours some
receive fines but the rebels are coming
in from the cold no longer feeling like
golf's outcasts at their first live
event in England since a proposed merger
with a long established series of course
it's about the money yes I mean you know
every professional golfer on the planet
is uh is competing for financial gain
and that's that's just a part of it but
it's it's not all about that but cash
seems Central to the PGA and DP world
tours caving in to combine commercial
operations with the golf division of
saudi's public investment fund from a
business aspect I think it's um
I think it's exciting to see them grow
the game of golf to grow football to
grow all sports that they want to grow
should there be any waryness that it's
you might be a sort of taller geopolitic
sport is just a way of actually Saudi
yeah gaining influence or should Sports
people just reap the benefits
I'm not here to talk about
them here to to go out there and play
some good
these golfers form the backdrop to a
strategy about so much more than sport
by effectively taking control of men's
golf Saudi Arabia is adding another
sporting sphere of influence in a
mission to diversify the economy away
from oil and cleanse the Kingdom's image
having the biggest brand in football
helps with Cristiano Ronaldo leading an
influx of stars to the Saudi League
Roberto firmino is the latest
Mahaba Anna Steven Gerrard and his
former Liverpool teammate Stephen
Gerrard accepted a manager's job there
this week
but sports stars are Accused by human
rights activists of neglected concerns
to accept Saudi riches rights abuse is
the PGA Tour called deplorable when they
went to court to thwart live a year ago
before backtracking a sport reunited by
a peace deal that's still being pieced
together even the players who risked
their reputations are unclear as they
compete again at Centurion Club where
ghosts Breakaway began in acrimony a
year ago all that seems clear is Saudi
Arabia is calling the shots and not just
in golf Rob Harris Sky News
Hertfordshire
well that was Sky News at 10 coming up
we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
newspapers in the Press preview
including this story on the front of the
eye which says we could see mortgage
rates of seven percent by the end of the
summer well tonight we'll be joined by
the daily mirrors associate editor Kevin
McGuire and the sun on Sunday's
political editor Kate Ferguson back in
just a moment
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
well there's this guy news in just a
moment the Press preview a first look at
what is on the front pages first though
a reminder of our top stories this
evening the NHS has marked its 75th
birthday with health Minister Maria
Caulfield telling Sky News that waiting
lists will probably get worse
Israel has said its forces have now
fully withdrawn from the Janine refugee
camp in the occupied West Bank following
a two-day military operation with the
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu has
warned that more raids could still
happen
and of course has heard how a man found
guilty of treason over a threat to kill
the queen was inspired by Star Wars and
an artificial intelligence chatbot
[Music]
hello there watching The Press preview a
first look at what is on the front pages
time to see then what is making the
headlines with the daily mirrors
associate editor Kevin McGuire and the
son on Sunday's political editor Kate
Ferguson welcome and great to see both
of you front pages though let us start
shall we with
the I which says mortgage rates could
hit seven percent by the end of the
summer the financial times has a story
concerning the increasing cost of
government borrowing
he Express accuses members of the House
of Lords of wanting to defy the will of
the people in the handling of these
small boats crisis
the star reports on the trial of a young
man who's accused of breaking into the
grounds of Windsor Castle where the
crossbow in 2021 and now claims he was
goaded to kill Queen Elizabeth by an AI
chatbot that is also the main story for
the Daily Mail AI chatbot told Windsor
intruder
the mirror speaks again to the TV
presenter Fiona Phillips who yesterday
revealed Her diagnosis of Alzheimer's to
the paper
the guardian hears that lung cancer
diagnoses among women now outnumber
those among men for the first time
the Metro aims to raise a million pounds
to go towards the cancer treatment of
toddler Holly Reeve
and the times reports on the labor
leaders kirst armor pledging to put
speaking fluently and clearly at the
heart of the national curriculum
well a reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
those papers will you watch us so let's
head to our guest tonight Kevin McGuire
and Kate Ferguson and Kevin why don't
you kick off with the eye this warning
which they had in yesterday's paper of
four more rate Rises to come seven
percent even by the end of the summer
no absolutely mortgage brokers uh
warning that's what uh it could cost to
take out a loan buy a home moving up to
six percent uh now huge financial
headache for people who uh either coming
off fixed term mortgages were used uh to
very low interest rates or uh trying to
get a first mortgage but it's also a
massive political headache for the
government because as the I say now the
majority of conservative voters blame
the government for the rise I think that
will go back to Liz and Tross of course
there have been other factors since but
the Tory the UK Tory government's taking
the hit and then I run up to the general
election people having to pay more for
their mortgages is a huge vote loser but
not everyone has a mortgage in this
country do they Kate so the problem is
you're trying to have a bank of England
Intervention which has an immediate
impact and many of those have fixed rate
mortgages so the squeeze seems to be
lagged and therefore take longer so
those people are in more pain can I put
it like that
yeah what you're seeing is the pain kind
of delayed and so as people come off
they're fixed they're going to be
whacked with these extra charges I mean
six percent seven percent these are eye
watering
um mortgage rates compared to what we've
been used to in recent years and it's
going to be really really painful I mean
Kevin Kevin's totally right the Tories
if any what are the toys if they're not
the party of home ownership and there is
a big danger here that the public or
their voters blame them for this
mortgage pain and I think it's going to
be interesting to see these by-elections
coming up because some of the um there's
some research out there which sort of
shows which seats could be particularly
hit by this mortgage Crunch and one of
the seats that looks to be particularly
hit is Selby which has a by-election on
July 20th so it would be very
interesting to see the result there do
we see the beginnings of this kind of
mutiny of the mortgage holders against
the Tories yes and some suggestion we'll
get the report on uh the groping
allegation towards the MP Chris pincher
um you know very soon tomorrow
Parliament standards Watchdog you know
will um that trigger a by-election we
wait and see
um you know they're racking them up the
conservative party aren't they
um one difficulty for the government the
other in the ft is that government
borrowing costs as well you know are
starting to to look extremely ugly and
that impacts all the spending on all the
public services and all the pressure and
all those services that we've heard so
much about Kevin
yeah no absolutely there we are um
government selling four billion uh of
debts called a guilt uh it's now it's
now costing rates not seen for uh
something like 25 uh 25 years uh this is
this is a huge problem of course getting
the national debt down was one of Rishi
sunak's own goals a lot of gold he said
himself by the end of uh end of year
it's actually gone up and topped 100 of
GDP for the first time since since 1961
but he was gonna have to pay a lot more
to serve as that national debt well debt
in itself will then go up and there'll
also be less for public services as the
government plans you know a budget and a
queen's speech and a financial statement
there are those big set pieces in which
you would try and change the political
mood ignoring them for a moment those
by-elections which Kate mentions and
they're going to be absolutely uh
incredibly difficult even if your whole
selfie and you just hold it uh it's you
it might mean you're not going to go
completely down but isn't mean you're
going to win a general election you're
still on for something about something
for hiding but now the government having
to pay more to service the debt will
just increase the debt total and so it's
almost everywhere you look uh today in
the papers or in tomorrow's papers is
economic bad news and that's a bit of
both for individuals voters families and
businesses but it's also political
Dynamite for the government well the
Metro has picked up on uh one family who
are trying to save the life of their
young daughter
um who suggests that their only option
is go to a private U.S clinic now trying
to privately raise those funds of
something like a a million pounds we've
had lots of cases like this and you know
the cost of medicine goes up and the
specific types of treatment do we just
not have it here in the UK
well in this this story which makes the
front page of the Metro tomorrow it
seems to be of the tragic little tale
about the little girl who has a rare
form of cancer so you're looking at very
experimental therapy which is why it
seems to only be available in the US
have you say her family is Raising I
think it's a million pounds to try and
raise the money to send send this child
to that experimental therapy and it
looks like they've already raised
something like 300 000 so you you see
the generosity of the British people
there and but it's interesting it comes
on the front page of the paper tomorrow
we've obviously just marked the 75th
anniversary of the NHS today and the
Rishi tsuna kissed Armor All in
Westminster Abbey kind of paying homage
paying tribute to the NHS today but
scratch beneath the first surface and
our National Health Service is in quite
a lot of trouble spiraling waiting times
people struggling to see a GP or doctor
people struggle willing to see a dentist
and what's clear is that it's going to
be one of the crunch issues of the next
election and whatever party gets into
government next time Tori or labor I
think you're going to see them start to
Grapple with what do we do to reform the
NHS we can't keep pouring billions and
billions and billions into it and just
seeing worse and worse results yes but
we will because you know the
population's Aging
um and the the revolution in healthcare
in terms of medicine and Tech will
continue
um for example the things listed today
um AI to speed up breast cancer
diagnosis a trial starting next year
that suggested that the UK was the first
healthcare system in the world to offer
whole genome sequencing for rare
diseases and cancer a warning from the
Tony Blair Institute you know this adapt
or die that the NHS needs to fully
embrace the tech Revolution it all costs
money Kevin doesn't it as we get older
so the pressures won't go away
no no we're we're living longer which
which is a great thing we require more
Medical Care to do so and ways of being
discovered to save people who would have
once died you're right all costs money
Innovation costs money new technology
costs money
um prevention programs cost money but
we'll save in the long term a shifting
to communities away from hospitals to
meet new health care needs well that
will cost money in a transformation no
it's it's incredible and satisfaction
levels with the NHS as we saw a way down
on it 75th birthday but people still
hold it very dear there's widespread
opposition to charging for for treatment
um well any government that says it
would uh start charging I think would uh
would would suffer very severely um at
the polls given the NHS as the nearest
we have to a national uh religion as
Nigel laws for Tori Chancellor said back
in the I think it was in sometime in the
in the 1980s but you know this story on
the front of the the Metro
it is somebody having to go private uh
because there's a gap in the NHS they
tried a stem cell transfer plant in for
this little girl uh of Birmingham Way um
it didn't it didn't work so they're
trying to raise that million as Kate
says 260 million raised in five days but
it's it's an area where going for some
treatment called CR cart therapy at a
U.S Clinic yeah it's it's it's worked
for some other people
um see the desperate family why they're
trying to do it but you've got to say on
the you know on the on the on the 75th
anniversary of the NHS I'm a huge
support of the NHS uh it is it is a
failure maybe it's only a small failure
compared to some of the bigger failures
that you can't get this in the UK it's
just not there a wait list by the way uh
Health Minister they're going to go up
further from a record of 7.4 million
that was another of Rishi surax I think
we will just call them own girls now
when he's uh his own goals that he seems
not be here to be able to score in the
right net he's putting them in his own
end yeah well they still say they're
optimistic I've got many of them but
you're right this is going to be a
tricky one I think isn't it record
demand record delays waiting lists
simply a sign of demand outstripping
Supply strikes don't help covered
backlog doesn't help and you know that
the whole thing is very difficult
um Kate I was going to move on did you
want to just you wanted to say something
I think
no it feels like with the NHS you know
there's just so many problems piling up
and up you know you solve one strike
another one seems to be announced you've
got the covert backlog I would say that
while obviously Ai and Innovation cost
money it probably would also save money
in the long term there's so much
repetition wasted man hours in the NHS
okay yeah and I think they're definitely
trying to push that way aren't they um
including piloting a blood tests which
could detect cancer before symptoms
appear I mean in a sense we should be
heartened by all the changes but you
know a long way to go um Kate why don't
you take us through the just stop oil
protest at Wimbledon you know big delays
of people trying to get in because of
searches this was a jigsaw box was it um
that allowed this protest to happen
yes this is perhaps the country's most
hated man now who leapt out from the
stands to unveil this kind of Jigsaw box
which had this orange confetti and the
tennis players had to kind of Scrabble
around on the floor to pick it up it
obviously interrupted play and we're all
on high alert to see if they do it again
this week the thing with the just the
oil protesters is that they're just
doing you talk about Rishi sunak's own
goals these are just massive own goals
for them you know each time they disrupt
a national sporting event Wimbledon we
saw it at the snooker and it was a it
was a different group but related animal
rising at the Grand National they just
seem to infuriate the whole country as
well our head has left as our hands and
you just think what are you doing don't
you realize you're people telling people
against your cause
um and this comes on the day where the
Home Secretary had
the police ran for this round table to
talk about what more they could do to
crack down on these protesters because
while everyone's on high alert while
there's kind of airport style Security
checks at Wimbledon to try and catch
these people before they go in it seems
that they're still getting in and
disrupting all these sporting events it
also comes on the day where NASA
satellite imagery shows that the Earth's
energy heat imbalance broke more records
a lot more heaters accumulating which of
course much of it absorbed by the oceans
which have been rising so you know how
do you get your message across is it the
wrong approach or do people need to sit
up and take notices and not try and get
cheap fossil fuels again uh despite the
costume
yeah I'm absolutely with a cause I'm not
I'm not sure the protests draw attention
actually normally to the cause at all
what's now described as performative art
it's the protest itself and to think it
was a rather a nice touch using one of
wimbledon's own jigsaws that you could
buy in a shop and have now been
withdrawn but it's gonna have a really
tight security but these these people
are absolutely non-violent they're not
threatening anybody physically they're
not trying to get knives or weapons in
and I think it's almost impossible if
someone's gonna stick some confetti down
their pants you're gonna Discover it and
then they're going to go on a shot and
buy a jigsaw and as though those
protests are just stick there they're
actually impossible to to stop okay but
your question there whether the practice
uh as a long-term impact which is the
right direction for them anyway stay
there both of you Kevin Kate stay there
lots more still to come including King
Charles has given Scotland's crown
jewels but a ceremonies like it outmoded
rituals are discussing not in just a
minute
[Music]
I think they're trying to push women out
of every aspect of public life and and
really make them prisoners in their own
homes and beauty salons are actually
quite important because they're women
only space where women can go and and
have community and have support and and
this is happening in a context where the
Taliban have not only banned women and
girls from most education and most
employment but also completely abolish
the whole system that have been set up
to deal with um with domestic violence
so a beauty salon might be the only
place that a woman could go to look for
help it's interesting because the
Taliban
um while they've pushed women out of
most government jobs and most NGO jobs
they have been a little bit tolerant of
women working in the private sector and
this seems like a sign that that too may
be
um maybe being taken away from women
which would be their last access to
income in a situation where the country
is in a very dire humanitarian crisis
one of the things that's quite
frustrating is that now almost two years
after the Taliban takeover and after
this Crackdown has begun we still see
diplomats who who have this idea that
somehow if they say the right thing to
the right member of the Taliban
leadership or if they find the the good
Taliban and get them to talk to the bad
Taliban that somehow there's going to be
a change but what we see is actually the
Crackdown continues to intensify things
are going in the wrong direction and
it's time for some some more vigorous
and and new thinking about how the
International Community should respond
the damage that's being done to
Afghanistan right now will will take
decades and and generations to recover
and and one thing that's important to
say is that while there's this
devastating harm to women and girls
there's also terrible harm happening to
boys because the Taliban is is gutting
the curriculum and so we'll have an
entire generation of young people girls
and boys who
um you know have been raised in a way
that's terribly harmful to them and to
their country and to the rest of the
world
I'm Greg mylam and I'm Sky's Chief north
of England correspondent
foreign
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
Press preview with me once again Kevin
McGuire and Kate Ferguson welcome back
to both of you and Kevin let's go to
your paper shall We The Daily Mirror um
which continues the news about Fiona
Phillips who has revealed that she has
Alzheimer's which is as she has said has
taken a whole big chunk out of my life
but also her families as well
yeah it's right it's ravaged her family
lost a mother and father to it now it's
as she put in her own words uh come for
for her but she's she's incredibly sharp
bright funny mischievous uh but you know
she's been dying she was diagnosed last
year she was only 62. all all of a
sudden she can't remember some recent
conversations or dinners with a husband
Martin Frizzell the head of this morning
over on ITV um which is very defined
because she's saying look
um we gotta find a cure and she's taking
part in drug trials which she hopes will
help other people down down the line but
um
it's it's it's incredibly sad and tragic
uh I know many families will have
experienced it but of course she she
will know where this leads from having
seen her mother and father
um
uh be taken by it and she really she did
a TV documentary uh on it and you know
spoke about
her mother screaming in a home and so on
so it's
I think it I think it must be
particularly difficult when people so
close and near and dear to you uh I've
gone with this that
it's now claiming you because you will
you will have seen the end game and uh
and it and it isn't Pleasant
and you will know um because she will
have looked after her mother and father
how much she will need to be looked
after in the future how many you know
repetitive phone conversations there'll
be you know how things have to be
labeled how Diaries have to be written
how lists have to be made
um you know she'll know all of that will
put a lot of pressure on her family as
well so that you know adds as you say to
to the difficulties for for her uh you
know the knowledge of it all
um okay let's go to the uh Metro shall
we um Charles the first crowned by the
Scots
um
some great pictures lovely red arrows
today uh some controversy two protesters
in the crowds and the greens not showing
up
oh yeah well you sort of get this a bit
don't you I sort of handful of
protesters in the crowd saying oh we
don't like the king or whatever but I
think most of us quite enjoy the
pageantry and I certainly always enjoy
it when they sort of get any like Crown
Jaws out and dress up and get formally
for the formal coronation up in Scotland
the whole country was watching it when
it was back down in Westminster recently
so I think this is all quite good fun
isn't it most people just quite enjoy it
and I think the protesters are probably
just a little bit bah humbug
nothing screams uh concern for the cost
of living crisis than uh having a big
bathrooms
including a 22 000 pound new sword
I thought the Scotland's got a like a
higher proportion of Republicans I think
there's still a minority I'm not
pretending it's going to rise up against
Charles The Unwanted and put him out but
it seemed a rather General shrug of
indifference in uh Edinburgh more people
seem to be concerned there was a big
traffic Jammy caused that's just the
people you heard
that one okay don't they I mean what's
the point of having monarchy if you
don't have the pageantry the giant
swords the big hats isn't that the point
yeah and the history goes back as you
know to James the first of England and
Scotland James VI of Scotland it's been
all going on a long time and uh you know
for some people it was a great day out
there we are both of you say thank you
very much indeed see you